Jamilah baaga often drives up this windy
and bumpy track to mount Bhutanese guida
she's an anthropologist who focuses on
development and human right issues and
runs dicey mud the Moroccan NGO is
behind a water project up on the
mountain
that's why they've placed these nets
here at an elevation of 1,200 meters the
nets catch the fog drops of water form
on the mesh today it's sunny but fog
often envelops the mountain it comes
from over there it comes in waves it
rises higher and higher till it's all
around you we could even die here
because you can't see where you're going
the climate is very dry here in
southwest Morocco on the edge of the
Sahara Desert rain falls rally climate
change is bringing more frequent periods
of drought people travel up to three
hours to fetch water
most are farmers they're at the mercy of
the soil and the weather as are their
livestock harvesting fog should make
life easier
three years ago Darcis mud entered into
a partnership with a German NGO called
visage Tifton or Water Foundation to
pursue R&D to optimize the harvesting
technology industrial designer Peter
taught vine tested a range of net
materials the mesh has to be tough to
withstand strong winds has to trap a lot
of water and be easy to install we use
rubber expanders hook them in stretch
them a little and the whole construction
is in place and stable and it moves with
the wind
the test phase is over next year a
larger fog harvesting installation will
be built
it'll consists of 31 collectors the
project will receive an award at the
upcoming global climate change
conference in Marrakesh I am in love
with this kind of approach to looking at
our environment as a living entity and
not simply as a refuse or for a garbage
dump or a place where we are getting our
resources for our own advancements and
that's it and the tale of progress is
today in a crisis and we know this and
we see this every day with the pattern
of climate change the fog harvesting
project includes a delivery system
piping the water down from the mountain
to the homes of residents in the area
like the suzanne family they've had
piped clean water for a year now Lesley
Dodson knows the family well she's an
American researcher who focuses on
communication technology and development
here she's worked a lot with the women
the new water supply has changed women's
lives dramatically instead of spending
hours and hours fetching water they now
have time to learn to read and write the
changes are expansive so the programming
should meet people in the community you
know beyond just the sit in the water
infrastructure
there's the pipes there's the technology
but then there's women's programs which
might be literacy which might be
numeracy children's programs that'll
that's the water school there's work for
men so I think that what this water
project does is set in motion really big
changes in the community it's foggy up
here about half the year water vapor
condenses on plants and on the nets up
on the mountain a single square meter of
mesh can yield up to 22 liters on a
foggy day that means the new complex
could produce as much as 37 thousand
litres of water a day
for the surrounding villages
for Mohammad Hamal II this means he has
a job again he helped set up the test
installation now he'll work on the
permanent one Mohammed and many others
here was skeptical at first they never
thought that Fogg could prove to be
useful before I saw it I thought the
idea was very strange I asked myself is
it really possible to turn fog into
water I never heard of such a thing I
couldn't even really picture it for
Muhammad growing up water was always a
scarce resource for his young siblings
drinking water out of a tap is the new
normal when it grows thick the fog that
often enshrouds butum is guida can make
the mountain terrain dangerous but now
it also brings a blessing